vous pensez peut-être que nous allons
parler de théâtre aujourd'hui et vous
n'avez pas tort mais nous allons aborder
le sujet du théâtre forain des centaines
de familles qui sillonnait la france
pour présenter des opérettes et des
spectacles
ce monde du théâtre forain il vous est
peut-être totalement inconnu on vous
invite à le découvrir
elle était très attendu en vive ou
plutôt dans les villages voire savons
c'est des dizaines de caravanes au loin
a annoncé l'arrivée des compagnies de
théâtre au four en
tête des troupes de théâtre itinérante
ça qu'ils se déplaçaient de village en
village avec leurs baraques boucleur
théâtre en bois leurs baraques
démontable et puis bien sûr tous leurs
costumes leurs décors leurs accessoires
de scène les troupes se déplaçait donc
dans des caravanes comme celle ci pour
aller jouer des spectacles devant les
villageois dans les spectateurs il
restait pour des périodes assez longues
de deux trois mois chaque soir les
comédiens jouent un spectacle différent
pour faire revenir les villageois dans
leur répertoire une centaine de pièces
allant de l'opérette au mélodrame du
vaudeville aux marionnettes ces
représentations sont données en famille
est l'une des plus célèbres d'entre
elles ce sont les critères cavaliers sa
famille créteur s'est installé après
l'arrêt de leur théâtre en 1974 ils se
sont installés à cheville qui est tout à
côté d'artenay donc c'est un petit peu
là à partir de cette famille que le
musée a ouvert mais depuis l'ouverture
depuis voilà 95 on a dans les réserves
plus de trois mille costumes accessoires
et décors de scène d'une vingtaine de
familles dont des costumes voilà qui ont
été gardés heureusement par ces familles
très souvent ils ont conservé tout ça
les costumes les décors les accessoires
tout sauf les baraques elle-même les
théâtres démontable qui ont été laissés
de côté le début du 20e siècle marque
l'âge d'or du théâtre forain mais le
déclin de la profession commence à
partir des années 40 les comédiens se
lasser s'en vont tout comme le public
qui se tourne vers le cinéma et la
télévision
à partir des années donc cinq ans il y
avait plus qu'une cinquantaine de
troupes qui tournait en france et
jusqu'en dans les années soixante dix
après à partir des années 70 il y avait
de moins en moins troupes et ça a été la
fin des théâtres démontable à partir de
7 ans le musée du théâtre itinérant est
le seul témoignage qu'il reste de cette
époque et de cette vie extraordinaire
donc maintenant qu'on a découvert
l'univers du théâtre forain eh bien on
va parler avec vous lydia lydia vous
êtes un enfant de ce théâtre en fait
c'était votre quotidien je fais partie
de la quatrième génération du théâtre
créteur cavaliers qui a été créé en 1925
oui donc du coup une grande famille de
personnes qui ont sillonné les routes de
province à tout à fait alors racontez
moi là on est devant quoi qu'est-ce qui
a face à nous une roulotte une caravane
alors nous préférons le terme caravane
bien qu'il soit de toute évidence
question d'une roulotte alors cette
caravane appartenait à mes grands
parents ils ont acheté un
comédien et mais clarion qui plus tard a
fait une carrière dans le cinéma et
c'est dans cette caravane qui est né mon
père en 1922 et alors vous c'était dans
le sang en fait votre ce théâtre forain
vous l'avez toujours vécu et vous l'avez
pratiqué jeu laissera ticket bébé je
peux dire je suis entré sur scène dans
les bras de marie jeanne et de fantine
plus tard j'ai enchaîné les rôles
d'enfants comme tout le monde comme tous
ceux de la profession jésus et le p'tit
jacques du de la pièce homonyme j'ai
joué cosette enfants que cette jeune
fille beaucoup plus tard j'ai enseigné
les rôles d'ingénuité et marc à rien
s'est arrêté à l'aube de mes 30 ans on
va les voir à l'intérieur justement
parce que c'était chez vous avec plaisir
ça vous rappelle des souvenirs du coup
d'être dans cette caravane oui oui c'est
assez
inexprimable
non la porte du souvenir de l'émotion de
oui
le tour du propriétaire donc là c'était
une chance chambre donc de mes
grands-parents bon leurs meubles
respectifs
chacun le sien chacun le sien les
costumes par contre les costumes de
scène était dans une autre caravane là
il s'agit des vêtements du quotidien de
du jour est alors avoir ce témoignage
encore aujourd'hui est de pouvoir le
montrer aux générations de 2021
moi mon but c'est de faire connaître de
faire connaître ce qu'était le théâtre
itinérant dans toute sa véracité et
heureusement bon le musée est là pour
effectivement résoudre se veut se veut
au quai n'est pas seulement le mien mais
de toute la corporation et notamment des
de ceux qui nous ont précédés de mon
père mon grand père est tout tout tout
la corporation des théâtre ambulant
surtout que c'est un témoignage qui
n'existe nulle part ailleurs voilà le
musée la seule traçabilité et je peux
dire que depuis 2005 notre profession
est représenté dans toute sa vérité avec
énormément de respect et d'authenticité
si vous et découvrir ce que c'est le
théâtre forain peut-être rencontrer
lydia qui pourra vous raconter son
histoire elle aussi et bien c'est ici à
retenez qu'il peut venir